دبلوماسيه جافه يقابلها استعداد للملء
الرابع لسد النهضه الاثيوبي القاهره غاضبه
مما تصفها بقرارات ادي سبب الاحاديه وتطلب
فزعه عربيه لمواجهه التداعيات الكارثيه
على حصه مصر من يهنيل اتهم وزير الخارجيه
المصري سامح شكري اثيوبيا بالاستمرار في
ملء وتشغيل صد النهضه دون اتفاق ملزم
وانتهاكها لقواعد القانون الدولي ومخالفه
بيان مجلس الامن الدولي الرئاسي الصادر في
سبتمبر 2021
في كلمته خلال الاجتماع الوزاري لجامعه
الدول العربيه تحدث شكري عن تعويم مصر على
الدول العربيه لدفع اثيوبيا الى التخلي عن
سياستها الاحاديه غير المتعاونه على حد
قوله
الملف مرشح للتصعيد وسط تراجع فرص استئناف
المفاوضات المثمره بين الدول الثلاث
المعنيه في نير الماضي كشفت صور حديثه عبر
الاقمار الصناعيه عن تحضيرات اديسبب لبدء
التعبئه الرابعه للسد توضح الصور فتحه
بوابتي التصريف اعلى الممر الاوسط وتوقف
تربينين عن العمل مع استمرار عبور المياه
اعلى الممر اكثر من مصدر مصري دق ناقوس
الخطر بشان المرحله المرتقبه ويقول انها
ربما ستكون الاخطر من حيث التداعيات
السلبيه المتوقعه منها في ظل استمرار
اتهامات لاثيوبيا بالسعي الى الوصول
المخزون مياه من السد يبلغ نحو 30 مليار
متر مكعب المسار التفاوضي غارق في
الاتهامات المتبادله بعرقله التوصل الى
تجاوز الخلافات وايجاد حل سلمي يرضي جميع
الاطراف والمشهد حاليا او الواضح منه هو
مضي سبب في خطط الملا بغض النظر عن موقف
دول المصب واستعداد القاهره لللجوء مره
اخرى الى مجلس الامن خطوه لا يمكن القيام
بها دون توافق مع الخرطوم التوافق غير
مضمون استنادا لمصادر مصريه تصف الموقف
السوداني في هذه المرحله بغير الواضح
تماما الخرطوم من جهتها سبقت ان اوضحت ان
غياب التنسيق مع اثيوبيا سيؤثر سلبا في سد
الروسيرس وخزان مروي ملء رابع مبرمج في
اوج ازمه السد بين الدول الثلاث ودون
تحقيق مطلب مصر والسودان لجدول زمني متفق
عليه قانونيا وفنيا مستوى مياه النيل تحت
رحمه حسابات سياسيه معقده وحرب دبلوماسيه
طويله